ك
[موسيقى]
هو في متناول اليد ولكن هذا الطفل يتعلم الكلاشينكوف في الفصل
أ ليس طفلاً، فهو إرهابي، بل طفل في رأيي تشايل
كان من الممكن أن يعطي ضربة افتتاحية أكثر إيلامًا بـ 100
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين قتلوا في البداية، نعم، هناك رجال حماس، وهناك المزيد
20 الانش هود س 100 هذه ليست المعرفة الكاملة
ما هو متورط وغير متورط وبريء
محفوظ تريد حقا أن تقتل 100 الذي قتلني
اضطررت إلى إنزال 1400 شخص في غزة
ضربة مؤلمة كما في الطيور الجارحة في البداية
والبقرة الحديدية التي قتل فيها العشرات من رجال الشرطة
كتب 100000 هزي انت و ريج ثاني على ما أعتقد
إذا قُتل 1400 شخص، فمن الممكن أن تقوم بعملية عسكرية
وأنت تعرف ماذا، لا أعرف كم ستحصل أيضًا
في النهاية، في البداية ستصل إلى الأرقام ثم ستذهب إلى NAN
عن وقف وكف المختطفين تحدثت في سياق
ضربة ضربة النار يجب أن تكون أصعب
من مكة رأينا تسيكا يقول بالعبرية البسيطة لا يوجد
إن الجدال حول هذا الأمر ليس أقل من دعوة للإبادة الجماعية
إن الدعوة إلى قتل 100 شخص هي دعوة للقتل
مع ما لا يقل عن ذلك، بالمناسبة، جلس الناس في السجن
أمام محكمة العدل الدولية فقط
القراءة ليست عن التنفيذ فقط
الحقيقة هي أنهم جميعاً مرتبطون بحماس، دعنا نقول أن هناك علاقة
في المدرسة، هناك إرث أن هناك معلمًا يتقاضى راتبًا
ومن حماس لديه ثمانية أطفال في المنزل الذي يحتاجهم
ولإعالتهم سنقتله، فهو ابن الموت
قال لي هامس لأنه يتقاضى راتبا من همس
من لحم الخنزير في رأيي إذا كنت تريد معرفة لحم الخنزير في النهاية
من هو من الناس، أولاده، أولاده، لا كيف، كيف
قلت: انفصلا، لا أعرف، لقد اتصلت بهم
لكن الآن جدعون نريد إلغاء الحساب
تحدثنا إليكم عن المؤتمر منذ أسبوع
لكن في تركيا، لن نرتقي إلى مستوى التصريح الاستفزازي
نزاع قلت عنه
المسرح ماذا قلت دعونا نرى
أنا
أبدا أبدا
لذلك
k والخطوة التالية التي تتحدث عنها هي أنه يتحدث عنها
من ماذا
عندما يكون الدم ثقيلا وأيضا السعر الاقتصادي مرتفع جدا
عالية جدًا مع حقيقة أننا طرحنا السؤال
كم يمكنك الاحتفاظ بأمر من هذا القدر
العديد من الحشوات النظيفة مع مرور الوقت لا توجد طريقة
افعل ذلك بسرعة إذا كان أي شخص هنا يتوقع أي شيء
وهي أشياء سريعة فلا يفهم العمق
المشكلة ولا أفهم كيف يبدو الحل وبالتالي
أسمع جميع أنواع الناس يقولون لماذا لا
لنفترض أنهم يجلبون المجارف لتفكيك غزة بأكملها
أننا سوف نضرب جميع المنازل فماذا كان الأمر
المساعد هناك اسم لمدينة تحت الأرض، وهناك اسم للأنظمة
لم يتم العثور على أسلحة، وبعضها غير موجود على الإطلاق في المنازل
التي ننوي تدميرها وسيدخل البعض إلى المنازل
أن التدمير لا يمكن أن يتم بهذه الطريقة، بل يجب أن يتم بطريقة ما
محترف تمامًا يعتمد على الذكاء المدروس
في الميدان، من واحد إلى واحد يذهب إلى الآخر
للمرة الثالثة وإلى الأبد لتنظيف غزة حتى نتمكن من الحصول على
الهدف الذي نريده أستطيع أن أفترض أنك شاهدته
في الفيديو كامل ولكن لا أستطيع أن أتخيل ما
لقد شعرت أننا نأمل حقًا أن يكونوا كذلك
أ في الوضع